[Musique]
ça va de fabrice ricard de moi dans les
yeux
qu'est ce qu'il ya eh ben dis donc ça
s'arrange pas toi fils normand non je ne
suis pas certain d'avoir un charmant
compris ton expérience c'est pas comme
cela qu'il faut utiliser les bouchons
pas du tout aller tous les sujets mais
tu es aveugle
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tout mes skis
son toit
bonsoir mon gamin tout cas encore sinon
majesté en we genre ouais je sors de
chez le torino 1 et là qu'est ce qui t'a
dit 1 il m'a fait tousser au le méchant
on a fait honneur
je suis en train de perdre la face à ces
extraordinaires un bon tout ça pour vous
dire que nous allons jouer avec des
bouchons aujourd'hui est ce que tous
contents et moi nous y perdons pas notre
temps en de futile expérience nous
allons directement au fond du sujet nous
avions plus difficile du sujet très
délicat
alors maintenant on nous appelle pas en
gros plan la faire parce qu'il faut que
je vous explique ça sérieusement vous
prenez deux fourchettes que vous plantez
dans un bouchon qui les attendait et
faire pivoter sa légèrement pour que
vous puissiez voir l'astuce colossal et
la toque c'est tombé je leur fais le
relever leur fait vous avez plantés dans
le bouchon une aiguille que vous allez
essayer de mettre sur la tête de
l'épinglé planté dans l'autre bouchons
elle me suis entraîné des heurts
j'ai failli devenir fou moi j'ai essayé
de faire ça sur le bec de nos trois
jours ça n'a pas marché non pas du tout
je suis très en vue alors regardez je
vais essayer de le faire je dis bien
essayer parce que si ça bouge
et voilà c'est ça un art et un artiste
c'est ça qu'on appelait alors ça c'est
étonnant vous pouvez essayer de leur
cher chez vous on y arrivera peut-être
pas du premier coup mais en principe
comme vous pouvez voir ça marche et je
vous signale que ce n'est pas du tout
aimante et il n'y a aucun trucage là
dedans je garantit l'authenticité de la
faire je le jure c'est bien la pointe de
l'aiguillon qui tient sur la tête de
l'épinglé bon vous me direz à quoi ça
sert strictement à rien mais le geste
d'autant plus beau qu'il est gratuit
simplement une petite expérience d'
équilibre c'est fabuleux
moi j'en suis pantois oui c'est ce que
tu as des idées étonnant bravo dégoûtant
bravo c'est bon si ça tiendra jusqu'au
bout alors je préfère l'enlever dommage
tu dois je laisse le moment je le laisse
comme ça si tu veux moi c'est comme tu
le dis en général ça tombe à l'automne
alors laissons faire le temps devenant
le jardin leur part dans le jardin que
moi j'ai j'ai à faire avec mes amis et
ben c'est une excellente musique je me
traîne
oui je le traîne pour aller retrouver là
là le village et j'en ai s'agit des
plumes a alors dit béni oui oui c'était
fort un son extraordinaire parce qu'on
va bien le maire quand même bon ami dé
tony encore un petit peu plus payer pour
le point oui oui on est prêts on est
pratiquement suisse savait où vas y
revient la paix de braves gens qui
brassent fait danser puis bras et tout
cas c'est toi cook encore un c'est ma
langue qui a fourché lafforgue à
lourches et oui d'accord oui nous sommes
d'accord bon le jeu des points communs
elles consistent pour vous et pour moi
même à découvrir quel est le point
commun qui unit tous qu'encore à bell
bell est à pouss moussu toucan belle
baie comeau su représentant chacun une
chose dont ils vont nous parler
maintenant alors qu'ils commencent une
personne généralement segal et voilà
alors si c'est quoi aujourd'hui
tu sais ce que je suis non de la neige
si vous êtes déjà liés aux sports
d'hiver d'ailleurs vous me connaissez
bien j'arrive à partir du mois de
novembre
je tombe à gros flocons puis je recouvre
les routes et les pentes des montagnes
en c'est beau c'est beau de voir surtout
le matin quand le soleil se lève comme
quand personne n'a encore passer ses
pieds ou ses skis sur moi puis tu sais
comment je suis je suis comme un grand
tapis éclatant je suis l'image de la
pureté et ça me va bien la pureté quoi
fabriquer un grand oiseau meehan oiseaux
qui ne ressemble pas du tout au tout
quand sans le vexer je suis plus
gracieux que lui
je suis un signe j'évite sur l'eau à ce
que tous qu'on ne peut pas refaire
j'ai un long coup de très belles plumes
que j'entretiens très soigneusement
je tiens toujours être impeccable je ne
supporte pas la moindre tâche et tout le
monde s'accorde à reconnaître que je
suis extrêmement décoratifs
ce qui encore une fois n'est pas le cas
de tous qu'on bombarde
je ne suis pas aussi gracieux que bell
bell jamais mais je suis très utile si
vous vous servez mois plusieurs fois par
jour car je suis un morceau de sucre
le matin dès votre réveil je suis là
pour votre café au lait je suis là après
le déjeuner pour que vous puissiez
tremper un canard dans le café de votre
papa tu et je suis là pour que votre
maman fasse de bonnes confitures à des
petits gourmands en panne et des rôles
art aussi bons les confitures enfin des
gens comme moi je vous le garantis il en
faut des kilos voilà alors nous avons
dit la neige pour tous quand nous avons
dit le signe pour bell bell et nous
avons dit le sucre / pouces vous sur la
page est qui et qui abolit j'aime bien
une petite idée quand même
avant je pense que vous avez la même
idée que moi
la neige le signe le sucre sont tous les
trois ce que je me trompe peut-être mais
enfin il semble que c'est la couleur
claire unis vous êtes tous les problèmes
et je travaille beaucoup
c'était bien tous les cas bravo à tous
les tons vous aviez trouvé vous autres
par fait d'accord pourquoi pas mais là
je viens tous les jours pas vous mais
surtout quand comme d'habitude alors tu
ne viendra pas ce que je vais me
préparer halloween c'est la surprise
fabrice est à moi c'est pas toi mais
c'est mon jeu est en jeu bon alors tu as
ton crayon j'ai mon crayon a refait
alors tu vas au tableau et je vais te
donner le mot et ben voilà c'est ça
qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est l'amour
c'est pas grave
bon tu donneras un petit chiffon tout
accord tenant un petit chiffon d'accord
alors je alors bombe à cette semaine
c'est un mot en cette lettre un enfant
difficile genre à cette lettre
oui tant tableau sera assez grand la
balade la première naturellement c'est
un fff
c'est sûr que tu n'as pas faire de
bêtises oh non non ils nous disent à
chaque fois là lors cette lettre je fais
donc cinq petits traits 5 p tit re est
la première lettre deuxième lettre
troisième lettre quatrième let 5e
lettres 6e lettres et j'attends la
dernière haie basse et un e
le voilà voilà très bien alors
maintenant à toi tu devines et alors je
commence par mes questions habituelles
est-ce que j'étais un animal
ah oui on va il a trouvé tout de suite
chez un animal est ce que c'est un
oiseau annoncé par l'oiseau est ce que
c'est un animal qui à quatre pattes un
basket qu'il en a plus d'ailleurs je
crois qu'il en a six qui sont assez
froids qu'il en a plus que quatre en
tout cas est ce que c'est un insecte
ah ben oui ça n'achète tu veux je te
donne la lettre du milieu à la 4e oui
alors la quatrième c'est un r oui va
trouver fini il va trouver tout de suite
alors on est est ce que c'est un tout
petit animal est un tout petit petit
petit animal est ce que ça pique à des
fois ça pichari ça pique
merci tout quand ça picote ça picote oui
je sais bien que ça chatouille ben je
verrais bien commençant par sa quelque
chose mais c'est le qui m'embête à la
fin oui pourquoi
ben parce que ça n'irait pas avec
l'animal en question avant ta qu'est ce
que tu as à trouver une fourmi une
fournée est bien fourni et âmes une
fourmi est écrit fourmis comme en bas
formule1
bah oui elle va très bien et tout cas
j'ai très bien vraiment eu approuvent
cette façon de faire bien la fourmi bah
oui ça fait une fourmi oui bah oui
évidemment et ben fogle aéré mieux en
mieux
1 une fourmi ça s'écrit f aut et m après
mm
vichy a remis ça c'est un et bien voilà
c'est une famille à basseau et rémy a
pas besoin de mettre à nu ou autre chose
ah bon il n'ya pas deux enfin au bon bah
c'est pas de ma faute la dame m'a fait
vraiment nimporte ballon bah c'est pas
de ta faute tu fais n'importe quoi
je sais je sais heureusement que tu
connais mieux les animaux ah oui à
l'orthographe et oui et comment je
raconte toujours des petites histoires
intéressantes alors sont les fourmis qui
avait lâché très fourni avec un homme
parce que parce que justement on dire
une fourmi non je sais bien que tout
toutes les fourmis qu'on voit c'est
celle qui transportait des petits bouts
de bois des graines de toutes sortes de
choses à ses fours mais là ce sont des
femelles c'est pour ça mais celle qu'on
appelle les les les ouvrières là on les
voit jamais ou presque jamais ce sont
des soldats
oui soldats grèce à l'intérieur de la
fourmilière pour pour la défendre contre
les ennemis as tu vois tu vois quand
même un fabrice à par l'orthographe
à oui oui je veux dire l'air trop grave
de fourmies connaît pas son nom mais je
connais rien de mettre un s quand elles
sont plusieurs
ah oui d'accord enfin avoue quand même
que je connais beaucoup de choses sur
les fournissent est vrai un par contre
je trouve que tout cancan
qui fait autant de fautes d'orthographe
que toi n'est ce pas avant nous raconte
pas grand chose sur l'organisation des
fourmis enfin passons ça c'est pas grave
qu'est ce que tu me proposes maintenant
je te propose un voyage à mouy un voyage
organisé par bell bell alors écoute ou
immédiatement bellevue
[Musique]
si m
mr et le mouton est aussi un bon moment
il ses dépenses de capitaux sur la route
et dans le temps
sa bande à alex pas simple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai ramon bel bel a cité trois points
très bien un joli fait savoir comment
s'appelle cette délicieuse chanson
ah oui je vous dis oui herbe flottant
sous le soleil après la publication
japon mais je reviens du japon alors
partir de maintenant tout le monde parle
moins fort bon effet mois de pris je
respire à four du pam
j'ai pris des leçons de sérénité à l'
empire du soleil levant au nom elle
était très agité sept ans s'immole un
bon sagesse fleury après l'orage comme
la branche de cerisier quand le
printemps précoce chasse les brumes de
l'hiver changé lorsque j'étais à
haguenau ohlund et 1040 deuxième qui
forment lempire nippon j'ai fait une
enquête sur mes origines
il a été prouvé que je descendais de
l'empereur ly mozilo lui-même arrière
petit fils de la déesse amaterasu ce qui
fait de moi la cousine de madame
butterfly ni l'honorable belles belles
pourrait-elle nous dire où elle a obtenu
ces précieux renseignements oui oui de
yamagata fukushima et entreprend à ses
moments perdus des recherches
généalogiques ce n'est pas son métier
en réalité il est chargé de surveiller
les girafes qui pullulent dans les
hautes montagnes
c'est un esprit curieux un érudit il
sait tout sur tout il m'a initié à l'art
des bouquets et des jardins japonais à
bassens amateur est l'oeuvre des petites
touffes de terre peut-être transformer
magnifier ce qu'il faut c'est posséder
la science regardez pouces moussu par
exemple mais il ne ressemble à rien de
quoi pousser sur cette tête s'il allait
au japon s'ils étaient pris en main par
un grand maître jardinier il deviendrait
superbe
moi j'aimerais bien mais le japon c'est
si loin un seul toit puisque si mes
doigts fait de l'est connaissent
maintenant tous les secrets de jardinage
rituel nous ont foutu à moi j'applique
trait sur sa personne les règles qui
m'ont été transmises par yamaha attend
prochainement
pensez à lui s'en ressentir une émotion
profonde il avait tant de noblesse dans
son costume traditionnel
il portait le pagne comme un prince
fabrice women now when des fêtes ne me
fait pas mal mais ne t'inquiète pas
qu'ils nommaient une branche des prunus
une branche de vie où tu sais pas si
c'est dû prunus massage est quelque
chose qui traîne comme à l'esat est quoi
oui festival
attention là attention au noyau oui oui
à droite plan ceibal mousseurs jeudi
près de la haye
excusez moi mes enfants mais il faut que
je me suis voilà je vais là-bas ne bouge
pas comme ça ne bouge pas ces petits
conifères petits conifères
c'est pas grand chose de comique en
maîtrise des choses comme ça c'est pas
mal ni faire genre vie
jean-pierre m'enfin c'est pas mal non
moi jamais la tête sur la tête oui alors
écoute sur la tête que moi tu veux j'ai
mis jeu mais sans la tête oui on va au
bout ce sera un pôle muséal elle
couronne une flamme quel beau jardin
c'est magnifique la ds qui tu as une
fleur une fleur oui j'ai une très jolie
fiancée mais devant nous ça mais juste
devant tu vas au dessus de la dent ou tu
de lagor les deuxièmes au dessus du nez
au dessus de la normandie dont elle ne
bouge pas pour eux c'est la même chose
c'est mignon mais moi j'aimerais bien me
voir quand même un peu tout le monde
vient me voir et bien morte montre lui
montre me demander pourquoi un miroir
paris tap à une chaleur à y perdre et
moi la loi lagarde abondant toi ah bon
c'est ça c'est ça un jardin japonais 1 à
l'aller magnifique cadeau chic et
belvèze s'occupe de toi avec plus
d'attention
maintenant mes amis je vous invite tous
à la maison j'ai rapporté du japon la
recette du gâteau national le pudding
c'est mon tricot jeu les réussit
admirablement bien vous vous régale
j'aime bien les gâteaux à beaucoup donc
je vois me dégage les gens mangent la
tête un bon je vais refaire ça d'une
façon délicieux bon eh bien mon cher
fabrice tu viendras manger de mompou dit
oui du pudding japonais sûrement oui
certainement
ou dit qu'elle m'appelle belle ducale
fabrice commence à m'agacer
au revoir mon petit la patinoire tu as
vu comment elle était à ranger mon coach
harrachi pas gâté
un écho encore oui au lieu de la
regarder béatement chiffre est tout de
même mieux de réfléchir un tout petit
peu rien au tas tu as frappé dans ce
qu'elle a raconté m'a pas frappé jeter
ne me frappe jamais elle t'a parlé du
japon ben oui tous entendu bon on est
tous noté qu'il y avait les
invraisemblances des choses qui
n'existent pas au japon tu n'as rien
remarqué toile au dessus du naïf tant
attendu mais voyons rien alors la girafe
au japon ça vous paraît normal ça quand
un animal courant du japon la girafe
l'om et un franchement non en afrique
peut-être mais au japon
et puis alors le son camarade impossible
de me souviens de son nom qui portait si
bien le pagne et julia cagé pas comment
il s'appelait chevalier à gages
honeywell et le bail est ce qu'on porte
un pagne au japon portail kimono et puis
alors il y avait encore autre chose qui
m'a frappé sur le plan culinaire
parce que je connais moyennement la
cuisine japonaise mais enfin je sais
bien qu'il n'ya pas de pudding dans la
cuisine japonais réimporter prodige me
parlerait du boeuf de kobe tu me
parlerait de la cuisine japonaise
classique je te dirai où est enfin là
l'angop pas les boeufs grocott blaisel
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes tout
quand le boeuf de kobe est un boeuf
spéciale qui est élevé d'une certaine
façon que l'on masse tous les jours pour
rendre sa chair plus tendres et qui je
crois même est massée à la bière si je
ne me trompe très spécial corée c'est un
endroit c'est le boeuf de kobe le
pudding non le pudding c'est en
angleterre et pis c'est tout et on le
masque on a souffert on masse le pudding
quand tu dis n'importe quoi je vais vers
la bouteille retenter cette expérience
superbe que tout le monde admire est
tout à l'heure on y va bref tu voyais
pas bien j'ai un peu le droit il veut
jeter des gars dégagés un peu l'oeil
droit
c'était pour lui faire plaisir tu sais à
maresché bien j'ai bien dit voilà ça va
mieux
non très bien
berti et la reprenons cette affaire car
c'est une affaire extrêmement d'état
souvenez vous le principe est simple un
bouchon avec deux fourchettes pour faire
l'équilibré
il y à une aiguille plantée dans ce
bouchon il y a une épingle plantés ici
dans l'autre bouchons se trouvant sur la
bouteille avec bien entendu la tête de
l'épinglé là est tout le style consiste
à faire tenir la pointe de l'aiguillon
sur la tête grille pain et ça croyez moi
cette part commode je vais essayer
encore une fois et ce n'est pas aimante
et bien si j'y arrivais comme tout à
l'heure je crois que oui
et voilà l'expérience est réussie à très
bientôt vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée au revoir à tous
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]